merci Bruno Belin de nous accompagner je
pense cette première demi-heure ateliers
de la Vienne rattachée au groupe les
républicains on va bien sûr parler des
mères les mers qui sont en première
ligne évidemment on en parle dans
quelques instants mais d'abord la nuit a
été calme dans le pays hier on l'a vu
Elisabeth borne a reçu les
parlementaires à Matignon sa priorité
c'est d'assurer le retour à l'ordre
républicain a-t-elle dit les revenus
selon vous ce retour s'attendrai
républicain les informations qu'on a de
cette nuit
ont tendance à le montrer mais c'est
essentiel et je crois que il faut saluer
l'ensemble des des services et de ceux
qui ont contribué service de l'État j'ai
vu dans le département où je suis élu
qu'en préfectoral a été présent en
permanence et force de sécurité de
gendarmerie en zone gendarmerie les élus
aussi ont été là dans les villes pour
rassurer j'ai vu à Châtellerault à
Poitiers bien évidemment et puis ça lui
aussi la sollicitation permanente qui
ont été celles des pompiers qui ont
répondu présent je crois que le fait
d'avoir sur le terrain l'ensemble de ce
dispositif a permis effectivement en
sept jours même si c'est toujours 6
nuits de trop ont permis de retour
relativement au calme ce qui est très
surprenant dans l'évolution on a
beaucoup comparé avec les manifestations
les émeutes de 2005 c'est voir que ont
été saccagés attaqué un certain nombre
d'établissements dans cet état les
établissements visés initialement en
2005 je pense bureau de poste les
mairies qui sont effectivement les
symboles les pharmacies et donc il y a
cette évolution dans les saccages et il
faut absolument que voilà le retour à
l'ordre républicain c'est c'est le mode
d'ordre général et donc merci un grand
merci à toutes les forces de sécurité
qui contribuent et ce ne sont pas que
des grandes villes et des banlieues qui
ont été la cible de ces émeutes il y
avait aussi des villes moyennes des
petites villes comment l'expliquer vous
alors ça on le voit aussi sur tous les
faits d'insécurité notamment dans les
commerces
vous avez dans les grandes villes
aujourd'hui beaucoup de systèmes de
vidéosurveillance et il y a moins dans
les villes intermédiaires on a vu des
villes de 4000 habitants
tonnèrent dans l'Yonne Montargis dans le
Loiret sont des villes intermédiaires
qui ont été saccagés il y a aussi le
fait
c'est un vrai sujet sur les réseaux
sociaux qui appellent à une mobilisation
des plus jeunes et ça fait partie des
réseaux sociaux
un sujet dans le débat qu'il y aura sur
cette question c'est forcément un sujet
de la majorité numérique du contrôle
d'un certain nombre
compte anonymes il y a un centre de
réseau qui fonctionne sur des comptes
anonymes qui ont appelé à la
manifestation vous avez vu comme moi que
des interpellés ont 14 13 12 ans un
moment donné effectivement il faut se
poser ces questions là c'est une
évolution de ces 15 20 dernières années
et on a vu le résultat depuis 6 jours
sur les mineurs il faut se poser
quelques questions il y en a à droite et
au rassemblement national qui disent
qu'il faut supprimer l'excuse de
minorité c'est votre cas
pénalement c'est un grand sujet alors
j'entends aussi on supprime les
allocations familiales ça fait 20 ans
qu'on entend ça je suis pas sûr que ça
soit forcément le plus efficace et puis
il faudrait trouver
une bonne idée il faudrait prouver que
les parents soient
pénalement associés ou correspondables
de l'acte et puis on en revient toujours
à la justice des mineurs des moins de 15
ans
[Musique]
on a quand même un système depuis
l'ordonnance de 45 en France qui est
bien établie alors le remettre en
question en fait sans doute partie mais
il faut se poser d'abord la première
question c'est retour à l'instruction
civique enfin je suis désolé mais si on
veut que les mers soient respectées que
les institutions soient respectées
je sais pas de l'éducation nationale ce
qu'on voit ces derniers jours moi je
pour une personne on est dans un pays
qui doit être fédéré qui doit trouver
ensemble les bonnes solutions je ne suis
pas procureur ni juge je ne pointerai
personne par contre il y a sans doute
des choses à améliorer
des gens il y a un système est-ce que
la l'éducation nationale a besoin de
moyens les l'ensemble des forces de
sécurité sur les territoires ont besoin
de moyens on arrive toujours après la
question des budget de qui paye etc il y
a des vrais choix à faire mais nous
devons nous poser la question de
l'instruction civique
vous savez on voit plus personne au
niveau enfant on voit plus d'un enfant
dans les cérémonies patriotiques au
monument aux morts
il faut apprendre à respecter ça et donc
ces messages là ils doivent commencer à
l'école après il peut y avoir des des
sanctions administratives alors on a
bien vu hier il y a du comparution
immédiate il y a eu des prisons fermes
de prononcer
est-ce que la case prison est une bonne
chose c'est un mineur et ce qui peut y
avoir des
sanctions administratives impossibilité
de PC son permis de conduire la
possibilité
pas forcément des sanctions financières
mais en tout cas des sanctions qui
toucheraient le jeûne
on va parler des maires évidemment qui
sont en première ligne face à ces
émeutes des rassemblements avaient lieu
hier devant les mairies du pays à midi
l'agression de la famille du maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses Vincent Jean Brun a
montré une nouvelle fois que les mers
étaient bien en première ligne face à
ses événements sont-ils suffisamment
protégés vous ne direz ce que vous en
pensez dans quelques instants Alex
pusard va faire pour nous le point sur
les mesures déjà mises en place par
l'État
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Bruno Belin et Alex
quelles sont les mesures que le
Gouvernement à d'ores et déjà mis en
place pour protéger les élus face aux
violences alors plusieurs mesures ont
été inspirées par le Sénat ces dernières
années on peut remonter à la loi
engagement et proximité de 2019 qui
prévoyait déjà des mesures de protection
des élus locaux face aux violences ce
texte avait renforcé le pouvoir de
police du maire et élargie la protection
fonctionnelle de l'élus et un système
d'assurance spécifique qui est financé
par la collectivité et puis en 2022 une
loi proposée par la sénatrice du groupe
RD sur le groupe radical Nathalie
Delattre avait permis aux associations
d'élus de ce constituer partie ville en
cas d'agression d'un élu dans le cadre
de ses fonctions et après la démission
du maire de Saint-Brevin victime de
violence et de pression de l'extrême
droite le gouvernement a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures de protection des élus
ah oui tout un paquet de mesures qui est
dessiné par le gouvernement avec d'abord
la création d'un centre d'analyse et de
lutte contre les atteintes aux élus ce
centre était une demande
utiliser le loco il va permettre de
mieux suivre ce type de violence
d'analyser le phénomène et puis de
coordonner les forces de l'ordre sur le
terrain ensuite 3400 référents atteinte
aux élus seront mobilisés dans les
brigades de gendarmerie et les
commissariats ils offriront un point de
contact de dialogue avec les élus locaux
sur et bien les violences et les menaces
dont ils font l'objet le dispositif à
l'armée lui va être renforcé alors c'est
très simple quand un élu se sent menacé
il appelle le 17 et il fera tout de
suite et bien l'objet d'une vie
vigilance renforcée de la part des
policiers et puis les préfets devront
analyser plus finement les différentes
menaces qui pèsent sur les élus selon le
principe une menace une évaluation les
forces de l'ordre devront aller
davantage vers les élus locaux notamment
pour leur permettre de porter plainte là
où ils le souhaitent et puis enfin le
gouvernement veut aggraver les sanctions
pénales en cas de violence sur un élu
pour les aligner sur les peines en cas
de violence sur un policier cela
pourrait aller jusqu'à 50 prisons et
75000 euros d'amende c'est un
durcissement des peines qui avait déjà
été voté té par le Sénat à l'automne
dernier dans le projet loi d'orientation
du ministère de l'intérieur mais cette
mesure avait été retoquée par le Conseil
constitutionnel car elle n'était pas
dans le bon projet de loi Bruno Belin
est-ce que selon vous la réponse du
gouvernement ces dernières semaines ces
derniers mois pour protéger les élus est
à la hauteur
c'est le même sujet que sur t-il y avoir
des dispositions pénales plus fortes sur
les mineurs on peut avoir effectivement
envie de charger le code vis-à-vis des
élus mais ensuite il faut que les
tribunaux appliquent on a bien vu avec
certains gardent des sauts on entendait
la chanson pas de prison voilà donc il
faut ça rien de se dire on va se faire
plaisir on va mettre des temps de mois
de prison ferme des sanctions si
derrière effectivement les tribunaux
n'ont pas les moyens et notamment les
moyens de placement des tensions parce
que c'est ça qui compte je vais prendre
un exemple parce que je pense à lui ce
matin évidemment pardon je parle du
département dont je suis lu le maire de
saints secondaires
Jean-Louis Bourriaud et vendredi il y a
une quinzaine de jours il s'est fait
menacer à bout portant par armes à feu
par un habitant de sa commune qui venait
de se voir couper l'électricité
je suis pas là pour commenter les
décisions de justice j'ai voulu
laisserai analyser er vous-même la
condamnation a été 200 € d'amende et 120
heures de travail d'intérêt général
comment voulez-vous qu'on s'y retrouve
alors les maires ils ont besoin
effectivement de dispositifs ils ont
besoin d'être
moi j'ai jamais été menacé physiquement
mais je me rappelle avoir été
engueuler pardon
verbalement sur une histoire d'un pays
de cantine donc il faut qu'on puisse
effectivement résoudre les problèmes du
quotidien sereinement les mères ce sont
les acteurs du quotidien un maire en
milieu rural il y a tout qui lui tombe
dès le matin sur les poubelles ont été
mal ramassées la rue est bouchée le
chien côté aboyer toute la nuit et le et
le maire il prend tout il est le
coordinateur de tous ces souffrances
morales de ces habitants donc
c'est important qu'il est des
dispositifs juridiques c'est évident que
force est à la loi et mais il a besoin
de ce lien quotidien moi je vois
toujours qu'est-ce qui marche chez nous
le lien avec les sous préfet trouver en
proximité les réponses à ces dossiers
assez préoccupations avec les services
départementaux les services de l'État
voilà il a besoin d'être rassuré je suis
pas sûr qu'on mettra un peloton que j'ai
hygiène devant chaque mairie il y a 35
800 mères en France 4 conseiller
départementaux 2000 conseillers
régionaux un millier de parlementaires
donc c'est quand même difficile
d'envisager une protection absolue par
contre j'en reviens toujours il faut
absolument qu'on rabâche et qu'on a une
mairie c'est sacrée une école c'est
sacrée la poste c'est sacrée et je suis
désolé enfin demain 5 du mois où les
bureaux de poste vont être hyper
sollicités dans le retrait
en espèces des minima sociaux on a brûlé
dans les quartiers populaires les postes
juste expliquer que ils sont du temps
eux-mêmes quoi enfin
il y a de la pédagogie et puis
effectivement après c'est est-ce que une
fois que les dispositifs seront
évalués seront décidés est-ce que on
sera suivi c'est pas forcément de la
prison c'est pas forcément d'amande mais
est-ce que tout atteinte à personne
ayant autorité
à sa compagne automatiquement d'une
suspension du permis de conduire du
permis de chasse et
des dispositions qui toucheront donc
quand vous écoutent on vous sent assez
sceptique sur une solution unique de
fermeté face à ces violences il y a le
besoin vraiment d'accompagner les élus
dans des écoles c'est comme le statut de
l'élu on en parle régulièrement donc une
chose est sûre je vous en reparlerai pas
dans 30 ans mais en tout cas ça fait 30
ans que j'entends ce sujet là donc
effectivement il est exacerbait
aujourd'hui parce que ce qui s'est passé
à L'Haÿ-les-Roses est inadmissible
inadmissible une voiture chargée qui
brûle qui fonde sur l'épouse les enfants
5 ans et 7 ans enfin vous vous imaginez
bien qu'on se projette tous dans cette
dans cette j'ai un petit garçon de 8 ans
évidemment c'est on est touché mais il
faut impérativement qu'on fasse de la
pédagogie qu'on parle qu'on se pose des
questions pourquoi les 12 15 ans sont
dans la rue Emmanuel Macron reçoit les
maires aujourd'hui des mères agressés
plus de 200 est-ce qu'il faut qu'il leur
annonce de nouvelles mesures bien sûr
paroles du président de la République
d'abord je trouve que c'est très bien
que le Président de la République
est pleine conscience du problème j'en
ai jamais douté il reçoit les maires qui
sont qui ont été impactés sans doute
dans leur commune il va y avoir aussi
une question très terre à terre des
moyens
financiers qui vont être mis j'ai vu ce
week-end dans les Yvelines à côté de
Montigny trappes Bois-d'Arcy
tout le mobilier urbain qui a été cassé
brûlé
la question est essentielle il faut
toujours il faut que l'État débloque un
fond il faut toujours en tout cas vite
remettre en ordre parce que si on laisse
les choses dégradées on rentre dans la
normalité et la normalité en la matière
ne sera jamais bonne est-ce que vous
craignez une crise d'évocation Bruno
Belin avec toutes ces violences qui
s'abattent sur nos élus
depuis plusieurs semaines comme je le
fais régulièrement vous l'imaginez bien
et puis comme le font tout tous mes
collègues Center je rencontre les mères
on voit que déjà certains disent non
représentera pas c'est souvent le cas
animal pour leur sécurité ou parce que
l'exercice est difficile l'exercice est
difficile donc
ils ont traversé un premier parti de
mandat covid pandémie masque je vous la
refais pas vous connaissez
qu'est-ce qu'il a besoin d'un maire
aujourd'hui de se projeter de mener des
projets il voit bien que c'est compliqué
aussi budgétairement à tout niveau donc
il le soutenir c'est effectivement lui
permettre d'aller dans sa projection de
ce qu'il imagine pour sa collectivité
mais par contre ce qu'on entend déjà ah
ben on aura du mal à être 15 j'ai
beaucoup de mon équipe parce que c'est
aussi dur pour le reste de l'équipe
parce que les conseils municipaux
auxquels on demande d'être présent pour
pallier parfois les carences du monde
associatif ou les carences d'engagement
ils sont là eux aussi le nombre de
conseillers municipaux dans les petites
communes c'est difficile à trouver
peut-être qu'il faut venir à 13 comme ça
a été
précédemment peut-être qu'il faut
laisser les communes rurales à 7 9 pas
choisir il faut quand même que soit
encadrer
ça sera difficile de trouver des
vocations on en revient toujours aux
questions après du statut de l'élu des
indemnités je vois bien j'ai entendu
dans les mesures quand même à la charge
des communes donc on en revient vous
savez on prend le sujet des des
indemnités parce que c'est un sujet très
clair ou des sont les budgets communaux
qui payent donc les élus ont parfois de
la réticence à ce
prémunir d'une dépense qui est prise sur
le budget et là dans les dispositifs
attaquer en justice saisir un avocat
c'est la commune qui va payer donc il va
falloir quand même trouver des moyens en
lien avec l'État qui est pas plus riche
on le sait très bien mais il va falloir
quand même trouver des moyens d'assurer
cette protection en tout cas il doit y
avoir des messages qui doivent passer il
doit y avoir aussi une surveillance des
réseaux sociaux on voit bien très bien
que l'évolution des réseaux sociaux a
une forte responsabilité dans ce qui
s'est passé ça a été dit multiple et que
les appels à la haine que les appels aux
émeutes soit clairement poursuivis mais
j'ai pas d'instruction à donner au
procureur de la République est-ce que la
situation qu'on connaisse ces derniers
jours va faire prospérer le
rassemblement national dans les zones
rurales pour vous c'est un ensemble de
choses c'est un ensemble de choses le
milieu rural
pour lequel j'ai une affection
particulière j'ai vide depuis plus de 30
ans
il semble blessés avec des fois ça
sentiment d'être oublié on ferme des
classes
il y a pas de transport en commun on est
isolé on se fait pas entendre vous
entendez jamais des émeutes du milieu
rural ou des saccages parce qu'on
respecte un certain nombre de choses
mais il y a ce sentiment d'oubli qui
fait que le message peut être favorable
rassemblement national et c'est là où
tous ceux qui ont à cœur la République
qu'on aime doivent se mobiliser pour
expliquer et entendu moi je
je me bats mais je continuerai à chaque
fois que je pourrais tant que j'aurai
mandat les fermetures de classe et on
peut pas demander au territoire il y a
eu un plan ruralité d'annoncer par la
première ministre et qui est venue à
Sauger moi j'ai hâte de voir comment
il y a une quinzaine de jours j'ai hâte
de voir comment ça va apporter ses
fruits parce que il faut que les
services publics les services de l'État
que les collectivités présentent en
milieu rural et les moyens de leurs
actions pour justement
montrer que la République est toujours
gagnante merci Alex à tout à l'heure oui
on parlera des besoins de main d'oeuvre
dans le secteur du tourisme exactement
ce sera à suivre dans le club on va
continuer à avoir l'actualité dans nos
régions va à Orléans retrouver Eric
Richard de la Nouvelle République
bonjour Éric merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous on va parler médicament AVEC VOUS
Eric puisqu'en centre Val de Loire votre
journal s'intéresse notamment à la
relocalisation de la fabrication de
médicaments qui concerne de près
l'activité économique de votre région et
vous allez nous en parler avant de poser
une question à Bruno Belin
oui on parle en effet et bien de
souveraineté sanitaire c'est un enjeu au
moins aussi stratégique que la
souveraineté alimentaire comme pour
cette dernière vous en souvenez les
dérives de notre économie mondialeisée
ont sauté aux yeux lors de la crise du
covid en 2020 ainsi notre pays dispose
bien d'un solide tissu industriel dans
le domaine de la santé plus de 3000
entreprises dans le domaine notamment de
la recherche
des produits de santé mais du côté de la
filière productive et bien c'est là que
le bât Blaise puisque près de 80% des
principes actifs pharmaceutiques que
nous utilisons en France sont produits
hors de l'Union Européenne
essentiellement en Inde et en Chine d'où
la mise en marche de cette reconquête
sanitaire annoncée par le président
Emmanuel Macron à la mi-juin d'une part
un plan innovation santé qui vise le
développement de médicaments innovants
mais aussi un plan de relocalisation de
la production pour éviter les pénuries
et ainsi renforcer et bien la sécurité
sanitaire le ministère de la Santé
élabore pour cela une liste de
médicaments essentiels sur lesquels les
efforts de relocalisation seront
prioritaires alors il y aura le
paracétamol bien sûr mais aussi certains
antibiotiques des anticancéreux ou
encore des médicaments nécessaires dans
le traitement des maladies chroniques le
centre Val de Loire vous l'avez dit est
intéressé au premier chef puisque la
région produit à ce jour plus de la
moitié des médicaments français et
disposent d'import ance outils et
laboratoires de production déjà c'est la
bonne nouvelle et bien les premiers
projets de relocalisation se concrétise
et je me trompe donc vers Bruno un
bonjour Bruno Belin tout d'abord alors
avec votre regard de sénateur bien sûr
mais aussi avec votre expertise de
professionnelle puisque vous êtes un
pharmacien bien tout simplement que
pensez-vous de plan de relocalisation il
semblerait que déjà et bien au-delà de
2030 on parle d'un projet dans le temps
long voire dans le temps très long
c'est un sujet essentiel puisqu'on a
bien vu depuis trois quatre ans que
toute la politique de santé était
peut-être pas à la hauteur de ce qui
pouvait arriver alors pardon de prendre
du temps mais j'ai déjà eu l'occasion et
à chaque fois qu'on a changé de mise à
chanter et la dernière fois
j'ai posé la même question à François
Beaune et Brown il faut effectivement
une grande politique de santé en France
une grande loi santé qui réformes à sa
donde de choses et qui évoquent tout du
début à la fin de la chaîne parce que on
est loin aujourd'hui de l'accès facile à
la santé alors sur la partie
industrielle
il faut comprendre que effectivement la
plupart des principes actifs ont été
cédés à certains de pays on sait la
Chine l'Inde l'Egypte on pense certains
médicaments qui ont manqué ça fait j'ai
alerté sur la pénurie de médicaments
lors d'une QG ou d'une question au
gouvernement la France est à sec six
mois avant qu'on voit effectivement des
ruptures de parastamol ou d'amoxicilline
dans les pharmacies donc on a un
problème de production tout simplement
aussi parce qu'on a plus voulu en France
d'usine de produits chimiques ça
s'appelle ces vaisseaux au niveau ça
s'appelle AZF pour ceux qui souviennent
de septembre de du 22 septembre à
Toulouse et donc on a délocalisé cette
production et donc à partir du moment où
on a délocalisé la production on a donné
à des pays autres le moyen d'avoir le
contrôle de la vente des principes
actifs et donc après c'est la question
du prix du médicament quand vous avez un
principe actif dans un médicament qui
est vendu à 2 euros en France ou qui est
vendu à 5 ou 6 aux Etats-Unis à qui vous
croyez que le détenteur du principe
actif va le vendre donc il y a cette
question du prix du médicament qui est
essentiel parce que depuis toujours
depuis 40 ans c'est gourré en France
pardon mais
il faut comprendre qu'on s'est dit ah
bah avec moins de médecins on fera moins
de dépenses d'assurance maladie avec des
médicaments pas chers on fera moins de
dépenses maladies sauf que le prix du
médicament qu'est-ce qu'il génère il
génère évidemment la recherche si on
fait pas la recherche on soit on
soignera pas nos enfants dans 15 ou 20
ans si on n'a pas appris du médicament
suffisamment à la hauteur on ne finance
pas la répartition la répartition c'est
ces sociétés qui permettent aux
pharmacies d'être livrées tous les jours
dans toute la France et donc c'est cet
ensemble de choses qu'il faut revoir y
compris puisqu'on parle du médicament la
formation la citation à un jeune
viendrait me voir aujourd'hui je dois
être pharmacien je sais pas comment lui
expliquer déjà que parcoursup c'est
terrible et on a inventé la lace on a
inventé le paces
ma génération pardon on a les s’inscrire
à la Faculté on passait le concours
passer à l'internat et puis on
s'installait en fonction de des
possibilités là aujourd'hui on venait à
peu près sur un millier de poste de
pharmaciens qui manquent on pense qu'à
la fin de la décennie il en manquera 6 à
7000 on a inventé en France les déserts
médicaux on va inventer les déserts
pharmaceutiques
merci
Eric merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous regarde la Une de La Nouvelle
République on va nous République
pour dire STOP aux violents urbaines
c'est allé une de votre journal avec
évidemment ces mères qui se sont
rassemblés hier devant les mairies de
France merci
Eric Richard puisque les vacances
approchent et les Français vont être
nombreux à prendre l'autoroute vous avez
évidemment travaillé sur ce département
j'imagine que vous encourager les
Français à les prendre mais en attendant
pour les Français qui vont prendre
l'autoroute est-ce qu'il faut taxer les
sociétés d'autoroute est-ce qu'elles
font trop de profits selon vous il faut
alors on les a nous avons additionnés
j'ai fait partie des sénateurs qui ont
auditionné les concessionnaires
d'autoroute on a eu 5 réunions sur ce
sujet là en commission de l'aménagement
du territoire c'est c'est un vrai sujet
parce que on voit bien que certains sont
contents de garder effectivement des
contrats longs que il justifie la hausse
des tarifs moi j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire hein les tarifs sont trop chers on
le sait parce que les sociétés se
rémunèrent aussi sur toute une série de
choses il y a pas que le pH quand vous
rentrez dans une station-service
l'essence est plus cher quand vous allez
faire une consommation dans ces aires de
repos les chanceux le coup est survé
donc il faut qu'il y a effectivement un
droit de regard sur ces contrôles
ces concessions c'est le rôle du
Parlement et c'est ce que nous avons
fait
commencé à prendre des routes
départementales et à voyager dans notre
pays qui est merveilleux
merci rien merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires on va
parler de l'impact des émeutes sur la
saison touristique est-ce qu'il y a des
annulations quel coût pour le secteur du
tourisme et de l'hôtellerie restauration
notamment vers ça dans quelques instants
d'abord on va continuer à parler
évidemment de ses émeutes et des
conséquences pour les élus locaux c'est
la ministre Dominique Faure qui nous
rejoint